some of the readings we've done in the
past weeks have suggested that you bring
in religion in order to humanize the
other so in order to establish tolerance
in a society that has come out of a war
you use religion to to make the other
and look more humanize him and this neat
how does this work in this in a society
I guess where you need the
secularization how do you who replaces
the role that religion has in bringing
tolerance about well I am ambivalent
about the role of religion I have seen
both religion can humanize and have a
positive role but religion can also
alienate and stupid if I and and have a
destructive role and I'm talking across
the board I am NOT an expert on Buddhism
but I know I've heard a different
example today then what we hear from say
Dalai Lama the most prominent Buddhist
leader mother Teresa who you should know
I've interviewed her three or four times
from Calcutta to former Yugoslavia where
she's from in Pristina and Macedonia and
so on mother Teresa lived like a saint
and yet say the serbian orthodox church
wants to make Radovan Karadzic a saint a
most notorious criminal who is
responsible for the death of tens of
thousands including the mass slaughter i
briefly mentioned of muslim men in in
three brain it's a-- i would say that we
need to affirm human freedom and dignity
of every human being in every context
and the religion is something that
should not be imposed
bye especially not by political rulers
and neither should it be uncritically
accepted as something we have inherited
from the generations past and so we be
as I would say vs the theologians and
ethicists need to critically assess
first of all our own religions our own
traditions and then working in an
interfaith or ecumenical setting we need
to call each other to mutual
accountability and ask what do we think
about divine purposes for Humanity and
how can we contribute to our
professional and religious communities
maturation so add vut will be faithful
to the best of its core as well as
somehow relevant then if I may use that
expression to be a transformative agent
in the contemporary world for those of
you who are Christians you will
recognize the metaphor Jesus uses for
his followers that they had to be the
salt of the earth and the light of the
world and so religions not at enmity
with each other but complementing each
other and working together for a better
future being carriers of hope i have
said yesterday in a totally different
context in boston you know our mission
may be for all religious communities in
this fearful dangerous we'll be living
how to how to diminish human fear and
anxiety and how to increase hope and we
approach it that way rather than
uncritically repeating slogans we have
learned from others and especially
dangerous slogans that have been abused
by political and
religious autocrats and dictators and so
on that's less dangerous that simply
counterproductive religion is an
authentic faith has something to do with
love with Redemption the forgiveness the
healing you know look at Desmond to toe
in South Africa and there of course many
many other examples look at Martin
Luther King in this country socially
relevant commitment to the vein and
engagement in changing the realities I
quoted earlier I wrote a little piece on
hope when we were under shelling and
threatened in Croatia and Bosnia and
this of course went to cost of a few
years later and hopefully it will never
be repeated in any of these places I was
writing on hope so I was doing a little
research and I found it st. Augustine
many of you will know the name one of
the true great giants comprehensive
minds who has built himself in his
thinking into the very foundations of
Western civilization's reflecting on
hope said hope has two daughters anger
and courage anger with the way things
are and courage to change them anger is
that holy indignation that motivated
Hebrew prophets and remember even Jesus
was angry okay so it's not anger as a
kind of a negative litany that makes you
bitter and causes ulcers but as that
holding they were whenever wherever
there is injustice and wherever innocent
people suffer if you don't get angry
something is wrong with your heart and
your conscience and religious leaders
religious communities especially need to
be awakened to more holy indignation
about the injustice in our world about
the violence about the poverty
and so on and then that holy indignation
that anger being transformed into into
courageous action that changes things
that make us angry in the first place I
don't know whether I've made that that
clear so religions are too long one more
question okay yeah i'll stop here sorry
st. Augustine I couldn't watch